[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin schönen guten Abend zusammen
Christian Otto übernimmt wieder den
sportlichen Teil der Sendung ja wir
gucken mal nach Hawaii guten Abend das
dann später jetzt zu unserem
themenüberblick
neuer Gipfel neuer Geist mehr als 40
europäische Länder Gründen die
europäische politische Gemeinschaft
mehr Geld bessere Arbeitsbedingungen
mehr Personal das fordert die
Pflegebranche und setzt ihre Hoffnungen
auch auf zugewanderte
und mutig kompromisslos mit schafblick
die Französin anni Erno erhält den
Literatur Nobelpreis
[Musik]
die große europa-idee der Gemeinsamkeit
sollte heute in Prag aufleuchten mehr
als 40 europäische Staats- und
Regierungschefs trafen sich zu einem
neuen Format namens europäische
politische Gemeinschaft und wir schauen
uns jetzt mal an wer sich da
zusammengefunden hat es sind alle
Staats- und Regierungschefs der 27
EU-Länder sowie aller Balkanstaaten den
südöstlichen Rand Europas repräsentieren
die Türkei Moldau Georgien und die
verfeindeten Staaten Armenien und
Aserbaidschan auch Länder die sonst eher
Distanz zur EU halten machen mit wie die
Schweiz Liechtenstein Norwegen Island
und Großbritannien vereint unter anderem
in der Solidarität mit der Ukraine aus
Prag Britta Hilpert
so viele europäische Staats- und
Regierungschefs und Chefinnen auf einmal
hat man selten gesehen 44 kommen zum
ersten Treffen der europäischen
politischen Gemeinschaft nach Prag
EU-Mitglieder
EU-Beitrittskandidaten ein Ex-Mitglied
und Nachbarn wir müssen reden meinen sie
alle über eine gemeinsame Strategie
gegen russische Aggression das ist gut
für den Frieden für die
sicherheitsordnung und
selbstverständlich ist auch gut weil die
Europäische Union dann auch ihre
Beziehung zu ihren Nachbarn von den
viele ja auch Mitglieder der
Europäischen Union werden wollen
verbessern kann es grenzt an ein Wunder
dass auch die nach Prag kommen die
Russland traditionell näher stehen wie
Serbien oder die eine Reihe von
Konflikten mit der EU haben wie die
Türkei es zeigt sich die Anziehungskraft
der EU ist so stark dass sogar Armenien
und Aserbaidschan die eigentlich Krieg
gegeneinander führen heute in einem Raum
zusammenkommen
auch ohne Beschlüsse soll eine
Gemeinschaft entstehen auf Seiten der
Ukraine mit einer gemeinsamen Strategie
EU-Mitglied eu-kandidat oder Ex-Mitglied
wir teilen doch einen gemeinsamen Raum
und oft auch eine gemeinsame Geschichte
wir sind aufgerufen unsere Zukunft
zusammen zu gestalten
doch die Krise schafft auch neue
Konflikte Deutschlands doppelwumms von
200 Milliarden nur für das eigene Land
verärgert nicht nur Polen the German
economy die deutsche Wirtschaft ist so
groß dass diese Unterstützung den
gemeinsamen Markt der EU zerstören
könnte meint der lettische
Ministerpräsident man müsse sich besser
koordinieren
man wird Olaf Scholz morgen in der Runde
der EU 27 fragen wie Deutschland wie die
EU helfen kann die Energiepreise zu
bremsen Vorschläge gibt es die Zeit
drängt denn der Herbst ist schon da
beobachtet den Gipfel in Prag Ulf ein
Zeichen der Geschlossenheit sollte
dieses neue Format senden ist es
gelungen
ich glaube was Putin und den Krieg von
Putin angeht ist die Verurteilung doch
sehr gelungen es gab dieses große
Familienfoto eine bunte Truppe könnte
man sagen und da war eben auch der
türkische Präsident Erdogan drauf der
durchaus manchmal sehr nah an Putin dran
ist aber jetzt hat er sich entschlossen
mit allen anderen Putin zu verurteilen
aber dann gehörte es eigentlich auch
schon mit der Gemeinschaft auf es gibt
eine große Diskussion innerhalb der
Europäischen Union wie man denn auf die
Energiekrise reagiert und im Hauptpunkt
der Kritik steht Olaf Scholz der
deutsche Bundeskanzler eben mit seinen
200 Milliarden Paket da sagen viele da
nutzt Deutschland ihre große Finanzkraft
und wird vielleicht andere schwächere
Länder Europäischen Union vom Markt
drängen es wurde sogar vom polnischen
Regierungschef von einem Diktat der
deutschen gesprochen Olaf Scholz hat
sich gewehrt hat gesagt andere Regierung
machen auch Programme und deshalb sei
das normal aber das wird die Wogen wohl
nicht Kletten und so wird es spannend zu
sehen sein wie morgen der Gipfel läuft
Fazit aus Prag heute es gab ein schönes
Familienfoto aber es gibt auch
Familienkrach einige Töne für morgen
sind also gesetzt Dankeschön nach Prag
Ulf Röhler zum Kriegsgeschehen in der
Ukraine und der Nachricht des Wladimir
Putin nach den jüngsten militärischen
Niederlagen den berühmt berüchtigten
tschetschenenführer und Hardliner
kadurov zum Generaloberst ernennt in der
süd-ukrainischen Stadt saporisha und dem
dazugehörigen Atomkraftwerk wachsen die
Sorgen am Morgen schlugen mehrere
Raketen in Wohnhäuser ein Nina kuscheln
berichtet
diese Frau kann nur tot aus dem Wohnhaus
geborgen werden bei einem russischen
Angriff heute morgen hatte sie keine
Chance zu entkommen ein Raketenangriff
auf saporisha nur 55 km Luftlinie
entfernt vom Atomkraftwerk nur einen Tag
nach dem Präsident Putin das AKW unter
russische Verwaltung gestellt und den
Westen damit einmal mehr in Aufruhr
gebracht hat es ist ein typisches
Kennzeichen der der putinischen Politik
er spielt ganz bewusst mit den Ängsten
des Westens auch mit den Ängsten der
Zivilbevölkerung und versucht so
Zugeständnisse zu erpressen
Zugeständnisse die es auf dem
Schlachtfeld gerade nicht gibt die
Ukraine meldet erneut weitere wichtige
Rückeroberungen
die Ukrainer wissen wofür sie kämpfen
gleichzeitig wird immer mehr Russen klar
dass sie nur sterben müssen weil ein
Mann den Krieg nicht beenden will
und inmitten militärischer Rückschläge
setzt Präsident Putin nun auf eine
überraschende Machtverschiebung er
ernennt den autoritären Herrscher der
Teilrepublik Tschetschenien kadurov zum
Generaloberst und gibt ihm damit den
dritthöchsten Dienstgrad seiner Armee es
ist sicher einerseits ein Signal an die
russische Generalität passt auf wenn ihr
nicht so wollt wie ich will dann komme
ich mit meinen privaten Freunden wie zum
Beispiel kadirov vorbei das russische
Verteidigungsministerium verbreitet
ungeachtet alledem erneut diese Bilder
Rekruten in der Ausbildung Rekruten die
schon bald für Präsident Putin in den
Krieg ziehen sollen
fragen wir nach bei für Bega in Moskau
für Putin setzt also den
tschetschenenführer kadirov als
generaloberstein inwieweit deutet das
auf eine mögliche Spaltung zwischen
Politik und Militär hin
also es ist zunächst mal ein Geschenk an
ramsam kadiro von das kam ja auch
pünktlich zu dessen 46 Geburtstag aber
natürlich zeigt Präsident Putin dadurch
seine Anerkennung dafür dass kadirov die
Kämpfe in der Ukraine von Anfang an
unterstützt hat sei es durch
martialische reden oder eben dadurch
dass er seine eigenen Kämpfer entsendet
hat die übrigens als besonders brutal
gelten Putin würdigt damit auch einen
Mann der und wertet ihn somit auf der
eben nicht dem klassischen
Militärapparat Russlands angehört der
wiederum Gerät ja immer stärker in die
Kritik aufgrund der Rückschläge entlang
der Front und wenn Putin der ja selbst
Oberbefehlshaber der russischen Truppen
ist jetzt nicht selbst in
Mitleidenschaft sozusagen gezogen werden
will dann braucht er schnell Schuldige
auf die die Verantwortung abgeschoben
werden kann und das erklärt dann
vermutlich auch warum jetzt eben
Politiker Propagandisten und
Milizenführer die es russische Militär
öffentlich und offen kritisieren dürfen
über die Planlosigkeit und auch die
Vetternwirtschaft herziehen dürfen und
im Fall von ramsankadirov dann auch noch
befördert werden
danke für die Einschätzung nach Moskau
für begab
der Verdacht auf Sabotage an den Nord
Stream Pipelines 1 und 2 erhärtet sich
das hat der schwedische Geheimdienst
bekannt gegeben die Untersuchung habe
bestätigt dass Detonationen große
Schäden an den Erdgasleitungen
verursacht hätten die schwedische
Küstenwache erklärte der verbliebene
Gasaustritt aus den Lex sei jetzt mehr
oder weniger unverändert das Gebiet ist
wieder für Schiffe freigegeben
dann zu den Kriegsauswirkungen bei uns
der Gasverbrauch in Deutschland steigt
zu stark eine gas-notlage im Winter ohne
Einsparungen von mindestens 20% werde
sich kaum vermeiden lassen können das
sagt der Chef der Bundesnetzagentur
Klaus Müller nach Zahlen seiner Behörde
lag der Gasverbrauch privater Haushalte
und kleinerer Gewerbebetriebe in der
letzten Woche fast zehn Prozent über dem
durchschnittlichen Verbrauchsniveau der
Vorjahre ein anderes großes Problem ist
der Notstand in der Pflege beim
deutschen Pflegetag in Berlin warnt die
Branche erneut vor einer
Mangelversorgung vor allem durch
fehlendes Personal 2011 gab es in
Deutschland in Pflegeberufen und 40.000
offene Stellen
2021 waren es mehr als 57.000 eine
Zunahme von
42%. um die Personalnot zu lindern
setzen immer mehr Pflegeeinrichtungen
auf zugewanderte Claudia das zeigt ein
Beispiel aus dem Saarland
seit sieben Jahren in Deutschland sie
hat ihre Eltern verloren auch deshalb
will sie sich für Senioren engagieren
ich musste viel reden und ich musste mir
die Aktie Leute reden war die ein zwei
Leute brauchen das
alle hier kommen aus dem Ausland aus der
Ukraine Russland Ghana oder Syrien ein
Jahr lang werden sie nun für eine
Ausbildung in der pflegefit gemacht
lernen medizinische Grundkenntnisse und
auch deutsch
wir haben jetzt den siebten Durchlauf
des Kurses 2017 sind wir gestartet und
es sind durchweg motivierte Teilnehmer
die alle in der Pflege landen wollen und
die Mehrzahl tut das auch im deutschen
Gesundheitswesen arbeiten immer mehr
Fachkräfte mit Migrationshintergrund
2013 lag ihr Anteil bei rund 17 Prozent
2019 waren es schon 22,5 Prozent nicht
nur wegen des Fachkräftemangels sind sie
längst unentbehrlich sie haben oft eine
besseren Draht zu Pflegebedürftigen
zugewanderten
das eine ist das sind natürlich die
Sprachkenntnisse darüber hinaus gibt es
aber auch sehr
kulturspezifische
Verständnisse von Gesundheit und
Krankheit Sterben und Tod Schmerz
erleben schmerzausdruck ja das ist für
nicht migrierte Pflegekräfte nicht immer
ganz leicht um diesen Punkt nächstes
Jahr will Steven success ihre Ausbildung
beginnen bald eine der Fachkräfte sein
die gerade dringend gesucht werden
der frühere Freiburger Erzbischof und
Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz Zollitsch hat
Missbrauchsopfer um Entschuldigung
gebeten und eigene Fehler eingeräumt in
einer Videobotschaft sagte zu habe es
versäumt Missbrauchsfälle offenzulegen
und stattdessen Vorwürfe intern
behandelt sein Verhalten habe den Opfern
zusätzliches Leid bereitet
Antisemitismus nimmt in vielen
gesellschaftlichen Bereichen in
Deutschland immer mehr zu davor warnt
die amadeo antonio-stiftung in einem
aktuellen Bericht insgesamt sei eine
Zuspitzung der Judenfeindlichkeit zu
beobachten jüngstes Beispiel in einer
Synagoge in Hannover ist gestern Abend
ein Fenster vermutlich durch einen
Steinwurf beschädigt worden dort hatten
mehr als 150 Menschen den Abschluss des
höchsten jüdischen Feiertages Jom Kippur
gefeiert die genauen Hintergründe sind
noch unklar der startschutz ermittelt
wer für heute einen Flug mit Eurowings
gebucht hatte der hob nicht unbedingt ab
denn wegen eines Pilotenstreiks bliebt
die Hälfte der Eurowings Flotte am Boden
250 von 500 Verbindungen wurden
gestrichen vor allem in Düsseldorf Köln
Hamburg Stuttgart und Berlin knapp
30.000 Passagiere sind betroffen die
Pilotengewerkschaft Cockpit fordert
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen etwa kürzere
Einsatzzeiten und morgen soll der
Flugbetrieb dann aber wieder weitgehend
normal laufen
jetzt der Blick nach Thailand wo eine
Blut Tat Entsetzen auslöst ein Mann
stürmte zur Mittagszeit eine
Kindertagesstätte und tötete dort mehr
als 30 Menschen überwiegend Kinder
anschließend brachte der ehemalige
Polizist seine eigene Familie um und
sich selbst Carsten Rüger berichtet
[Musik]
es sind Schreie der Trauer der Wut der
Verzweiflung Mütter Väter Freunde und
Verwandte können es nicht fassen am
Morgen hatten sie ihre Kinder in dieser
Kindertagesstätte abgegeben ein
friedlicher Ort des Spielens hier oben
in Thailands nördlicher Provinz nonboa
lumpu 500 Kilometer entfernt von Bangkok
doch am Mittag fallen hier Schüsse ein
Mann stürmt mit Schusswaffen und Messern
in die Kita er habe auf jeden gezielt
der sich ihm in den Weg stellte
berichten Überlebende viele Kinder soll
er in einem Schlafsaal getötet haben
unter den Opfern auch eine Schwangere
Betreuerin
der Amokläufer einen 34 Jahre alter
ehemaliger Polizist er war im Juni wegen
Drogendelikten aus dem Polizeidienst
entlassen worden als Sicherheitsbeamte
sich der Kita nähern ist der Attentäter
mit einem weißen Pickup auf der Flucht
schießt dabei aus dem Auto heraus die
Einsatzkräfte schreiben eine Fahndung
aus doch zu Hause angekommen tötet der
Mann erst seine Frau sein Kind und dann
sich selbst Ende einer Amok Tat deren
Hintergründe weiter unklar sind egal was
die Antwort ist sie werden wohl kaum
darüber hinwegkommen was am heutigen Tag
hier passierte
[Musik]
der
Literaturnobelpreis 2022 geht an die
französische Autorin anni Erno die
82-jährige erhaltet die Auszeichnung für
ihren Mut und ihre klinische Schärfe so
die nobel-akademie Erno wurde schon
lange gehandelt und ist jetzt die erste
Französin die dir den höchsten Preis der
Literaturwelt erhält und Thomas Walde
bringt sie uns näher
eine ehrenur reagierte am Nachmittag auf
den Preis den Sie gerade verliehen
bekommen hat ich bin sehr glücklich und
stolz
sind sie überwältigt nein überwältigt
nicht
sprachlich präzise selbst in diesem
Moment zuvor hatte das Nobelkomitee
seine Entscheidung begründete in einer
Tonlage die zur Preisträgerin passt
zurückhaltend und auf den Punkt
für den Mut und die klinische Schärfe
mit der sie die Wurzeln Entfremdungen
und kollektiven Beschränkungen der
persönlichen Erinnerung aufdeckt
Erno hat meist mit autobiografischen
Bezügen und immer authentisch und
angstvoll geschrieben vom Standpunkt
einer Frau über eine traumatische
Abtreibung über Affären mit einem
russischen Diplomaten oder einem jungen
Mann
ich bewundere ihre Arbeit Feminismus
Jugend die Sache der Frauen sie ist eine
inspirierende Autoren
[Musik]
die Bücher sind für junge Menschen
leicht zugänglich sie sprechen Frauen
und vor allem Mädchen sehr an
vor der letzten Präsidentschaftswahl
forderte Erno dazu auf die linke zu
wählen gleichwürdigte Präsident macron
heute ihr Schaffen ihre Stimme ist die
Stimme der Freiheit der Frauen und der
vergessenen des Jahrhunderts
sie empfinde den Preis als Verantwortung
sagt er nur weiter zu machen offen zu
sein für die Frauenfrage das
Fortschreiten der Welt den Wunsch nach
Frieden
[Applaus]
und wir sind beim Sport und weil
Christian und du schaust auf einem ja
erfolgreichen Champions League gehabt
schöne Tore zwei Siege was will man mehr
nach den Bayern hat auch Borussia
Dortmund jede Menge Selbstbewusstsein
getankt für das Prestige Duell in der
Bundesliga Samstagabend 4:1 beim FC
Sevilla eine Galavorstellung die Lust
macht auf mehr auch dank junger
Erfolgsgaranten
ihr juveniler Stratege dirigiert die
Borussia auch in Andalusien Jude
Bellingham in Abwesenheit von Reus und
Hummels schon mit 19 Jahren Kapitän
bereitet das 1:0 durch Guerrero vor und
tanzt sich durch zum zweiten Treffer
extrem elegant in der guten Gäste
Mannschaft eine Ausnahme Erscheinung
heute war Judith
herausragend wie viele Spieler heute
habt ihr gesehen wieso er auch die
Kapitänsbinde trägt obwohl er so jung
ist weil er heute Vorhang gegangen ist
wie auch der 17-Jährige Jusuf famukoko
Vorbereiter des 3:0 durch alle Jenni
eine Schwächephase mit Gegentor durch
ein nesri leistet sich Dortmund auch
geht daher nicht mit ganz breiter Brust
ins bundesliga-spitzenspiel gegen Bayern
München am Samstag nach Brands 4:1 aber
schon mit Selbstbewusstsein
selbstbewusst auch RB Leipzig das mit
dem 3:1 gegen Celtic Glasgow seinen
ersten Sieg in der laufenden Saison der
Königsklasse verbuchte zunächst brachte
Christopher nouku RB in Führung und nach
dem Ausgleich der Gäste machte andre
Silva mit einem Doppelpack den Erfolg
perfekt getrübt wurde die Leipziger
Freude durch den Kreuzbandriss des
Torwarts Peter gulaschi der nun länger
ausfällt
einen Tag nach der Trennung von Gerardo
s Joana wurde in Leverkusen Charlie
Alonso als neuer Cheftrainer präsentiert
der 40-Jährige frühere Bayern-Profi
fühlt sich bereit für seinen ersten
großen Job als Coach sein Ziel mit
modernem Fußball die Bayer 11 aus der
Krise zu führen erste Herausforderung
Samstag gegen Schalke 04
zum Auftakt der judo-weltmeisterschaft
in Taschkent hat Katharina Menz aus
Backnang Silber gewonnen der Klasse bis
48 Kilo ihr bisher größte Erfolg nach
drei Jahren Pause wegen der
corona-pandemie findet der auf Hawaii
wieder der legendäre Ironman statt die
Frauen um die deutsche
Titelverteidigerin Anne Hauck legen
erstmalig vor und sind seit knapp einer
Stunde unterwegs 3,8 Kilometer Schwimmen
180 km Rad und der Marathon alles schon
jetzt live zu verfolgen online unter
sportstudio.de und dem ZDF von 0 Uhr an
das kann wahrlich eine spannende Nacht
werden und wenn ich immer wieder
faszinierend vielen Dank Kristin nach
Nebel gibt es viel Sonne mit wenigen
Einschränkungen bleibt beim goldenen
Oktober und mehr Wetter gleich von Katja
horneffer um 21 Uhr die aktuellste
Nachrichtenlage im heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka genießen Sie den Abend
morgen hier für Sie Barbara halweg ich
sag vielen Dank und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend heute trennte eine kleine
Kaltfront am Mittag die 22 Grad hier in
Südostbayern von 16 Grad in
Norddeutschland so kleinere Kaltfronten
gibt es auch in den nächsten Tagen
Morgen zieht eine hier über
Schleswig-Holstein hinweg wechselhafter
wird dann zum Samstag die kleine kalt
von heute Mittag wie liegt aber jetzt in
der Nacht am Alpenrand zum Teil bildet
sich richtig dicker Nebel in
Süddeutschland im Norden bleibt es
dagegen klar und nur an der Nordseeküste
kannst mal ein paar dichtere Wolken
geben an den Küsten und unter den
dichteren Wolken am Alpenrand sinken die
Werte in dieser Nacht auf 10 bis 8 Grad
in der Mitte wird es deutlich kälter da
droht zum Teil auch Bodenfrost bei
Lufttemperaturen von zwei bis null Grad
die Temperatur morgen sind mild 17 bis
22 Grad erwarten wir und die Nebelfelder
in Süddeutschland die halten sich zum
Teil wirklich zäh das kann dann 11 12
Uhr werden bis sie sich auflösen in
Norddeutschland ist es dagegen sonnig
und erst am Nachmittag kann es dann in
Schleswig-Holstein mal für einen kleinen
Regenschauer reichen mehr Regenschauer
und kurze Gewitter gibt es dann am
Samstag im Nordwesten am freundlichsten
wird es wohl zwischen der Ostseeküste
und dem Oberrhein und am Sonntag gibt es
dann schon wieder goldenes Oktoberwetter
die neue Woche startet im Westen etwas
wechselhafter guten Abend